one on the ground
on the grounds and put it on the ground
don't drop the gun
drop it Cindy drop it drop it drop it
I'm telling you I'm telling you
officials in Kentucky Release Body and
dash camera video showing what led up to
an officer-involved shooting
down drop the gun on February 19th
officers with the Louisville Metro
Police Department responded to a mental
health complaint for a woman hitting a
vehicle with a gun and pointing it at
nearby people the suspect 52 year old
candy Marie basil had a history of
mental health crises body camera video
shows officers arrived to the scene
calling for Basil to drop the weapon
okay put you down put you down put you
down for me
put it down drop the gun
on the grandson put it on the ground
don't drop the gun
yeah
[Applause]
three officers on the scene call out to
Basil but she does not drop the weapon
hi what are you doing
foreign
[Applause]
throw it down
put you down for me I'm gonna talk to
you put it down Sit put your gun down
watch it
go ahead just okay put you down put you
down put you down for me
put it down dash camera video shows
basil refused to drop the gun and
instead walk toward officers on the
ground
[Applause]
put it down honey
body camera video from multiple angles
shows the moment officer Donald Brian
Wyatt opened fire drop the gun
drop it Cindy drop it drop it drop it
I'm telling you I'm telling you
should have dropped the gun drop the gun
drop it turn it down
put it down honey drop the gun drop the
gun
put it on the ground on the ground on
the ground
put it on the ground sweetie put it on
put it down put it down
after this all three officers rushed
toward basil video shows one officer
secure the vehicle nearby
car's clear another officer moves the
weapon basil was holding out of the way
at the same time the third officer
begins applying pressure to Basil's
wound as someone else approaches
officers yell for them to get back
saying it's an active scene who are you
get back back up man back up man back up
man back up it's a scene back up back up
basil was taken to the University of
Louisville Hospital for medical
treatment she survived the shooting and
was charged with three counts of wanton
endangerment of a police officer and one
count of medicine the officer-involved
shooting is still under investigation by
the Kentucky State Patrol officials say
no more details about the shooting will
be released until that investigation is
complete reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie